>> Greg: WELCOME BACK, IS
AMERICA'S FUTURE WRECKED AS MORE
WOMEN MOVE LEFT?
WOMEN HAVE CAUGHT THE WOKE
INFECTION WHILE MEN STILL MOVE
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
NEW RESEARCH, MY FAVORITE KIND
FINDS YOUNG WOMEN ARE
IDENTIFYING IS MORE LIBERAL NOW
THAN ANY TIME IN OVER TWO
DECADES WHILE YOUNG MEN ARE NOT.
ALTHOUGH MORE YOUNG MEN ARE
IDENTIFYING AS WOMEN.
[LAUGHTER]
AND IN THAT DIM REST STOP LIGHT
I HAVE TO TAKE THEIR WORD FOR
IT.
DON'T KNOCK IT.
WOMEN AGES 18 TO 29 OR AS LEO
DiCAPRIO CALLS THEM SENIOR
CITIZENS -- THEY COUNT
THEMSELVES AS LIBERAL WHICH IS
EASY WHEN THEY HAVE NEVER HAD TO
PAY FOR THEIR DINNER, AND MY
RIGHT?
>> FOR DUDES IN THAT SAME AGE
BRACKET ONLY 25% ARE LIBERALS,
YOU CAN FIND THEM BUYING CAT
FOOD ON THE WAY HOME FROM
YOGA -- LOSERS.
THAT NUMBER HAS BEEN THE SAME
GOING BACK TO THE LATE 90s
WHEN KAT WAS JUST 20.
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE?
GENDER STUDIES EXPERTS MIGHT
CITE ABORTION POLICY, ME TOO
MOVEMENT, THE RISE OF TRUMP
LIBERALIZED MORE WOMEN OR IT
COULD BE THEY ARE DELAYING
MOTHERHOOD SO THAT CONSERVATIVE
INFLUENCE IS BEING PUT OFF OR
MAYBE YOUNG MEN'S BRAINS ARE
LARGER.
>> A SEXIST WOULD SAY!
>> Greg: PUT THAT IN THERE.
LIBERAL OR MORE LIBERAL THAN
EVER AND MEN AREN'T, HOW DOES
THAT WORK IN THE DATING SCENE?
>> IT'S NICE TO FINALLY MEET YOU
IN PERSON.
I'M CURIOUS BECAUSE YOUR PROFILE
WAS A BIT VAGUE, HOW DO YOU FEEL
ABOUT FEEL ABOUT TRUMP.
>> TRUMP 20204!
>> HE'S THE WORST, I HATE HIM.
>> THAT IS GREAT TO HEAR, IT'S
HARD TO FIND AN IMPRESSIVE MAN
THESE DAYS.
>> SHE'S SERIOUS.
>> AND JOE BIDEN IS SO COOL AND
A STRONG.
>> EXACTLY.
I JUST WANT SOMEONE WHO CARES
ABOUT TRANSRACIAL CLIMATE
VACCINE EQUALITY, WHAT ARE SOME
OF YOUR PRIORITIES?
>> DON'T SAY SEX.
SEX EDUCATION FOR
KINDERGARTNERS.
>> SO IMPORTANT!
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE SHE'S BUYING
THIS.
>> DO YOU WANT TO GET OUT OF
HERE?
>> LET ME GRAB MY HAT.
WRONG HAT AGAIN.
>> I CAN'T EVEN LOOK AT YOU.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: ISN'T THAT THE TRUTH?
GUYS REALLY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
POLITICS IN A RELATIONSHIP, THEY
WILL PUT UP WITH THAT UNLESS IT
GOES TOO FAR, IF YOU ARE IN
ANTIFA BUT THERE IS GOOD LOOKING
PEOPLE IN ANTIFA SO THAT WOULD
NEVER BE A PROBLEM.
>> I THINK THEY JUST DON'T WANT
TO GET YELLED AT.
IF YOU'RE SOMEBODY WHO'S GOING
TO YELL AT THEM ABOUT POLITICS
AND BE SCOLDING, I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY WANTS TO DEAL WITH THAT.
PERSONALLY I DIDN'T HAVE THIS
LUXURY BECAUSE I WANT SMALLER
GOVERNMENT -- ANYONE WHO AGREES
WITH ME POLITICALLY LIVES IN A
BUNKER IN THE WOODS.
I NEVER GET TO MEET THOSE
PEOPLE.
>> Greg: THAT YOU EVER LET
POLITICS INTERFERE WITH THE
RELATIONSHIP?
>> NO, NOT EVEN A LITTLE BIT.
IF THAT IS THE FIRST DATE AND
THAT'S WHAT SHE BROUGHT UP I
WOULD'VE YELLED CHECK FASTER --
MEN ARE UNDER ATTACK.
YOU CAN'T BE A MAN ANYMORE IF
YOU HOLD THE DOOR OPEN YOUR
CHAUVINISTIC AND POSSIBLY
RACIST.
EVERYTHING A MAN DOES IS UNDER
ATTACK.
ALPHA MALES BAD -- EVERYTHING
THAT DEFINES A MAN, RUNNING INTO
A BUILDING AND SAVING SOMEBODY
FROM A FIRE, BAD.
MORE MEN ARE GOING TO START
GOING TOWARDS A PLACE WHERE THEY
ARE RECOGNIZED.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO BE LIBERAL
ESPECIALLY WOMEN, THERE SEEMS TO
BE MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR GROWTH
FOR WOMEN.
THEY BRING THE MEN, THEY ARE ALL
INDIVIDUALISTS.
THEY DON'T BRING OTHER WOMEN UP,
THEY BRING THEM AROUND AND TEAR
THEM DOWN SO BY THE TIME THEY
ARE IN THEIR LATE 20s THEY
BECOME CONSERVATIVES BUT IT GOES
BACK THE SAME THING.
EVERYONE WANTS TO CRASH MEN DOWN
IN THE SAME PEOPLE WHO ARE SUPER
LIBERALS WHEN SOMEBODY BREAKS
INTO THE HOUSE NO MATTER HOW
LIBERAL THEY ARE THEY WILL STILL
GO ARE YOU GOING TO -- AND
THAT'S WHEN I WOULD BE AS FAR AS
EQUALITY GOES, I FEEL IT WOULD
BE BETTER IF YOU TOOK AT THIS
TIME.
BECAUSE I RESPECT YOUR RIGHT.
>> Greg: OR HAND HER THE
GUIDE.
>> USE A LOT OF LETTER I
STATEMENTS.
BECAUSE I'M NOT GOING.
>> Greg: ISN'T IT A NATURAL
SPLIT IN A WAY THAT WOMEN
GENERALLY TEND TO BE MORE
LIBERAL AND MEN TEND TO BE MORE
CONSERVATIVE BECAUSE WE TAKE
MORE RISKS, WE ARE OUT THERE
HUNTING, THEY ARE GATHERING?
>> WITH THE HAND GESTURES.
>> HUNTING AND GATHERING AND
WHAT DO LIBERALS DO?
ALL THEY DO IS TAKE, TAKE.
>> IF YOU THINK OF THE GARDEN OF
EDEN.
>> Greg: I DO A LOT, THAT IS A
STRIP CLUB IN CHELSEA.
>> DID THEY MOVE IT DOWN?
IF YOU THINK OF THE GARDEN OF
EDEN, HE'S LISTENING TO WHAT GOD
SAID DON'T TAKE THIS ROUTE,
DON'T TOUCH THIS TREE AND EVE IS
GOING COME ON, JUST HAVE A FIGHT
WITH ME.
IT STARTED THERE, LIBERALISM
STARTED RIGHT THERE.
AND NOW IT HAS CONTINUED, IT'S
OUT OF CONTROL AND LIKE YOU SAY
WITH ALL THE VIOLENCE THAT'S
HAPPENING IN SOCIETY -- I DID A
FILM CALLED ROE VS. WADE, I
PLAYED THE JUSTICE WHO CAME UP
WITH THE ARGUMENT OF THE WOMAN'S
RIGHT TO PRIVACY.
THAT PHRASE BOTHERED ME, A WOMAN
WHAT ISN'T A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO
ABORT?
WHAT DOES IT HAVE TO DO WITH A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO PRIVACY?
THE LEFT IS ABLE TO
LINGUISTICALLY CAPTURE ALL OF
THESE WOMEN AND ALL OF THESE
RIGHTS AND ALL THIS OTHER STUFF
SO IT BECOMES A VERY -- THE
STATE WE'RE IN TODAY.
>> Greg: WHO CAPTURES THE
LANGUAGE CAPTURES THE BILL IN
THE BLANK FOR ME.
>> THE CULTURE.
>> Greg: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
TYRUS MAKES THIS POINT, THERE IS
AN ALIENATING ATMOSPHERE WITH
MEN AND IF WOMEN BECOME MORE AND
MORE LEFT WING, MEN ARE GOING TO
BE LESS LIKELY TO BE AROUND
THEM, THEY ARE GOING TO RETREAT
INTO WHATEVER, VIRTUAL REALITY,
SEX DOLLS I NEVER SEE THEM BUT I
HEAR THEY ARE GETTING MORE
REALISTIC EVERY DAY.
>> A FRIEND TOLD YOU THAT.
>> OR WOMEN FROM THE MIDWEST AND
THE SOUTH, IT'S NICE ALSO
MUSCLE.
>> Greg: I FORGOT ABOUT THAT!
>> WOW.
>> Greg: I'M GOING TO GO WITH
THE DOLLS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WE ARE TALKING ABOUT WOMEN IN
THE SEGMENT BUT I THINK
CONSERVATIVE WOMEN THIS IS YOUR
MOMENT, IF YOU ARE IN YOUR
20s, ALL THESE OTHER LEFTY
WOMEN DON'T WANT TO GET MARRIED
ANYWAY, SO FINALLY WHEN I WAS IN
MY 20s WHICH WAS JUST A FEW
YEARS AGO -- KIDDING, THANKS FOR
LAUGHING.
WHEN I WAS IN MY 20s ITS
COMPETITIVE.
IF YOU ARE A CONSERVATIVE WOMAN
IN YOUR 20s NOW THERE'S
PROBABLY FIVE REPUBLICAN GUYS
FOR EVERY CONSERVATIVE WOMAN,
ENJOY THE MOMENT, I THINK IT'S
GREAT.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: ARE THE WALLS CLOSI